you see the ice look at the ice so know
what partner whenever you got that type
of ice
you got to get your own ice partner i
got hold on i got you some ice partner
we go we're going to do this the right
way we listen
everybody thinks that we can't catch up
or keep up with these young fellas
listen partner
you know try to look listen there you're
telling petey hold on hold on petey hold
on peter you know you gotta take us a
break though but okay i'm gonna put mine
on we'll see yours a little bit later on
in the game we got you see the ice look
at the ice so know what partner whenever
you got that type of ice
you got to get your own ice partner i
got hold on i got you some ice partner
we're going to do this the right way
listen
everybody thinks that we can't catch up
or keep up with these young fellas
listen partner
you know try to look listen there you're
tom petey hold on hold on petey hold on
peter you know you got to take us a
break though but okay i'm going to put
mine on
we'll see yours a little bit later on in
the game we got